Our next guest made fashion history
as Victoria Secret's very first Australian angel.
But these days she's an accomplished business woman
as the founder and CEO
of her organic skincare brand Kora Organics.
Please welcome Miranda Kerr.
(audience cheering)
How are you?
Oh my gosh, I'm good.
As I'm sitting and doing my homework
and seeing all that you have going on
and with this year,
and you had your one child
and then you have your second child
and now you have your third child
and it's 2020 and everybody's trying to take on so much.
How are you, real talk?
How are you handling it all?
Yeah, it's,
it's a lot to balance with my company and my three kids
because I am still breastfeeding my one-year-old,
and I have a two-year-old,
and then I have a nine-year-old
who I'm obviously homeschooling right now.
So,
it's a lot to manage,
but we're doing it.
I mean, does it ever look and feel super hairball?
I'm having one of those days a little bit
where I'm just like,
I feel like I'm on roller skates on a very greased floor.
I'm just like, "Oh my goodness."
I'm trying to keep it all together
and it's not always easy.
I know, it's definitely not.
That's why I just like taking a breath
and bringing it back to the moment exactly where you are
so that you don't feel like you're too much into
what's gonna be happening next.
You're just right where you are.
And it's definitely something that requires
a lot of practice.
I have the word breathe actually tattooed on my wrist
and I forget to do it all the time.
I mean, I'm clearly breathing, I'm alive,
but did you find that side of yourself
that wanted to be wise and zen and clear and breathing?
When did it all start for you?
So, yeah, I grew up,
my grandparents pretty much raised me
because my parents had me when my mom was 17
and they're still together,
so much, very much in love, which is so cute.
And my grandpa
actually would bring home for my grandma
these big geode crystals,
'cause he was a house mover.
And so that's where my love of crystals came into it.
So he would bring them back
and there was a willow tree that we'd climb as kids.
We had the crystals at the base of the willow tree,
and that's the thing that I actually say now.
Someone told me once
that it's better to be like a willow tree.
In a storm the willow tree is so flexible and bends,
and then an oak tree
that people think and assume is so strong
is so rigid that it breaks in a storm.
So I try to tell people on my team from Kora,
with my company, let's be flexible like willow trees
and go with whatever's happening.
Don't fight against it.
Yeah, no, it's good to be more fluid and flexible.
And that's someone who literally,
before this morning started, I was like this.
So I get it.
I probably could have snapped in two with a soft breeze,
I was being so rigid.
I should get into my inner willow.
That's such a beautiful story.
What is the difference between
some of the crystals and their meaning?
Yeah, so the amethyst, which I have here,
is a great crystal for meditation and also sleep.
So I have a big one next to my bed.
I'm actually at Pisces, I'm born in February,
and that's my birth stone.
So I'm a fan and I'm gonna get a giant one next to my bed.
Exactly.
Then the citrine
is a beautiful stone
that actually brings about positivity and joy
and self-confidence.
Well, I identify with this rock.
I like to be very positive.
So with crystals,
so I'll talk you through the rest of them that we have here.
So the rose quartz, which is my favorite actually,
this is a very soothing, calming, nurturing crystal.
So this one is all about supporting your heart
and the heart chakra
and bringing in that very humble self-love and kindness.
And so it's almost like a big hug.
This is the way that I describe it.
So all of my products from Kora,
in the manufacturing process,
the crystals come out, they get energized by the sun,
and then they go back into the big vat,
and then all the ingredients touch upon it
and they're energized
with that beautiful, loving energy of the rose quartz.
And actually, I don't know if you're aware,
but on the back of our products,
there's also a positive word.
So for instance,
on the back of our turmeric two-in-one mask,
I don't know if you've tried this,
it's a really good exfoliant,
but on the back it has "radiant".
So a positive word on the back of each product
when we're using the products to remind ourselves
to get into that positive state and shift our state of mind,
because every thought we think
really does have an effect on our body on a cellular level,
and there's been so many studies done on that.
Oh gosh.
My body is probably like a sewer then
from some of my like self criticism.
I'm gonna work on that too.
(upbeat music)